- Let's close this one out,
with one last feel good story.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
I am always impressed
when artists can take
the most random pieces of trash
and turn it into eye-popping treasure.
It's super cool where people find beauty.
But we featured a few, such
artists, on the show before.
We even paired one with a younger sculptor
for a giant project.
Well recently, I came across
some art that's just as cool.
It's all intricate depictions
of animals and sea creatures.
We have this very creative
artist on the line right now.
It's incredible.
She's watching, NBC Connecticut at Three.
Everybody say hello, to Stephanie.
Better known to her
thirty-thousand Insta
followers, as Sugar Fox.
(crowd cheering)
What's up?
- Hi!
- Oh, my God.
First of all, your work is so beautiful.
You're so talented, can you explain more
about what it's made of?
- Thank you so much.
It's all recycled
materials, mostly plastics.
Things like, Tupperware,
toys, extension cords.
I keep it all basically in a
trash heap in my home studio.
It's been donated to me in bits and pieces
over the years by friends,
family, members of my community.
I've actually stopped taking donations.
Because, it's become so overwhelming.
It's just too much stuff.
But, in terms of what I like
to make, it's usually animals.
I mostly like doing animals as an artist
because of the personality and
the soul that forms in them.
And the final step to that point,
is just giving them a
name, I name everything.
- I mean, it's so crazy.
The seahorse, right now,
that I was just looking
at, it looks cool both ways.
If you just left it without the paint.
It's so cool what you do.
I just love that you see that.
- Thank you.
- It's such an incredible gift.
So, how did you get into sculpting trash?
Like, where did that, how did that happen?
- So, it's a really long story.
But basically, in 2017, I had been working
as a sign artist for a grocery
store for about five years.
I left that job very abruptly,
with nothing lined up.
So, I figured I would try
to be a freelance artist.
But with no income, I had
no money for supplies.
So, I had been following some
trash artists on Instagram,
and I just figured, you
know, trash is in surplus
and it's free, so it would be perfect
if I could figure it out, and
when I tried it, I loved it.
The response was really
overwhelmingly nice,
and here we are five years later,
and I'm really proud to
say that I am making it as
a freelance artist.
- Oh that's incredible, way to go man.
Take something you're amazing at,
and you're passionate about
and then making something
beautiful for everybody,
it's a really cool gift man.
Thank you so much Stephanie,
I'm liking your post right now,
all right?
(bell dinging)
- Thank you.
- And that's not all,
our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of Frixion
the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly, just you mam,
so they're going to give you
$1,000 just for being you.
(crowd cheering)
- Oh thank you.